Caption: and we really do need to pull together
Caption: the world is going at a kind of crazy
Caption: way I've got a lot of to the Kiwi this
Caption: morning it's doing fantastically and I
Caption: was like I'm here pizza key which is
Caption: from problems a North which is the only
Caption: city in New Zealand worse than the city
Caption: on wrongful detention ratified here
Caption: started by Kiwi right fantastic and to
Caption: come over because we are I do have a bit
Caption: thank you but a very lucky human being
Caption: to have a microsoft hololens which i
Caption: love sharing and if you want to have a
Caption: go on that ships of robots you might
Caption: want to look at the software you have it
Caption: around housing come out of the corner
Caption: also got this which is a representation
Caption: and where technology that to that in
Caption: some agendas you're going to have to
Caption: think about because this believe it or
Caption: not is it by working really hard this is
Caption: Matt he is a UNIX developer with us and
Caption: he is working on our the our team to try
Caption: and make house tools and their entire
Caption: real estate upon today you thought work
Caption: inside a 360 environment how many text
Caption: books do you reckon there are today
Caption: O'Reilly or whoever on how to design
Caption: within a 3d and one of sqx practices
Caption: that'll be none and this is what I want
Caption: to get to it getting talking about your
Caption: ability you that curiosity and talent to
Caption: invent for this carnival because he is
Caption: actually working incredibly hard there
Caption: particularly this is the only technology
Caption: I've ever worked with would have
Caption: actually sent in consumer testing a
Caption: customer to hospital with a knee injury
Caption: and somebody has vomited in waste bath
Caption: I'm not an easy technology equipment but
Caption: that's the challenge of the world we
Caption: kind of live in today you know you don't
Caption: get many manuals with these done effects
Caption: so you're lucky will I want to stop in
Caption: cheese's it's not your dad's Microsoft
Caption: is it but they're producing like
Caption: that this culture and I often give this
Caption: to all sorts of people some things I
Caption: don't have to explain it and is my time
Caption: beginner's guide to that's hard to
Caption: explain about your job and it's only
Caption: going to get worse I don't want to leave
Caption: you at the end of a sense of what I
Caption: think your job is which is literature an
Caption: economist telling engineers on Saturday
Caption: morning Mars Mars is really important I
Caption: show it's relative
Caption: second old seven one-bedroom unit octave
Caption: Studio do not wanna major immunise love
Caption: them dearly but someone will need to
Caption: start a real estate agency a lot and
Caption: then it isn't evil must because we won't
Caption: own everything allowed at that point
Caption: replies up in the conversation things
Caption: like anybody in society today because
Caption: what mom is about in this crazy moment a
Caption: political scientist on television
Caption: interview and Elon Musk about what the
Caption: political system will be on mass now the
Caption: world's changed isn't it asking a nerd
Caption: what the political system unknown is
Caption: going to be and we all love your team
Caption: from us don't we
Caption: holy what are that's true in favors
Caption: have a level of dictatorship to
Caption: democracy me whose democracy New Zealand
Caption: democracy worth this biblical
Caption: representation and nothing is done
Caption: Australian democracy was 2004 nobody
Caption: more like in the upper house American
Caption: democracy which you buy I know and it
Caption: has the right suicide and what it is
Caption: it's about a world where the rules are
Caption: off and this is an interesting thing to
Caption: me because there are people all around
Caption: Australia who are having the same
Caption: thought what if the rules were off
Caption: around property what if the rules were
Caption: off around jobs around science you know
Caption: all the things we now I'm going to work
Caption: everyday with as our minds it they
Caption: disappear on Mars now we got life is
Caption: going to get a million people to Mars
Caption: that's pretty impressive kind of a
Caption: better acclaimed we have 120 stars in
Caption: China
Caption: tell you what in see on and China you
Caption: couldn't see other side of the street in
Caption: the middle of summer
Caption: yes PNA looks quite good in comparison
Caption: 600,000 dollars to get this two hundred
Caption: and sixty two days we're going to have
Caption: the first people there in the next four
Caption: years it's just one but when there's a
Caption: bill that's a one-way ticket they're
Caption: going out in a minute
Caption: my grandad came to Australia 1928 on a
Caption: boat took in six months to get here I'll
Caption: tell you what slice it to month is going
Caption: to be a lot classier than the barbecue
Caption: came out
Caption: of MgO walk across South America Cape
Caption: Town purple curve Jesus when he landed
Caption: it look like that leaf is Sydney and we
Caption: secured a barrow grant I don't expect
Caption: you to know where it is but it looked
Caption: exactly like that it was about you're
Caption: out of there
Caption: the spirit that brought this people your
Caption: you your parents your grandparents to
Caption: this country look absolutely sending the
Caption: models right they've solved the
Caption: number-one problem that's not ear debris
Caption: it's a network of satellites that
Caption: deliver the internet he's got a
Caption: machinist scale of ambition I know what
Caption: you work on I get to work on you know a
Caption: portal that sells photographs of houses
Caption: quite like to be working on selling
Caption: going to Mars
Caption: there's my favorite video from the last
Caption: year why don't you see any if you all
Caption: would have brought the landing the
Caption: landing of the rocket back on the
Caption: platform that's pretty cool the like and
Caption: Landers drone doesn't look that flash to
Caption: me cuz I mean how big is it looks like
Caption: maybe size the car something like that I
Caption: just found this spider the other day
Caption: holy man that is a big throne and
Caption: it landed itself somebody wrote the code
Caption: for that that's cool that's amazing
Caption: engineering that is the most gigantic
Caption: thing I ever saw this is the world line
Caption: that's not thirty thousand years old I
Caption: am 52 years old I do genuinely take
Caption: pride in the fact that I've got a bunch
Caption: of 36 year old and all them coming in
Caption: towards all you they got to get to the
Caption: other parents inside well it's just a
Caption: bit too big hit the stage in live and
Caption: I'm conclusion this we might see the
Caption: same people you know or 52 I've
Caption: reinvented myself three times I'm only
Caption: as good as your only woods in the
Caption: digital economy for the last 15 years
Caption: that you've worked in a digital economy
Caption: for the last 15 years you're as good as
Caption: me just keep your eyes open so it's what
Caption: I've done another era in platforms and
Caption: media which you're going to have to
Caption: develop for and the interesting
Caption: gentleman you know in my lifetime I mean
Caption: in New Zealand pleading with me to 1936
Caption: and a New Zealand 1970
Caption: we had pcs and one of those the
Caption: worldwide love it is our first website I
Caption: really take up on that I use very
Caption: cleverly we call it virtual realities
Caption: well that one that's back you are out
Caption: out because suddenly in 2016 that's
Caption: incredibly relevant the world with
Caption: mobile and VR and I are now the
Caption: interesting thing that plays out on here
Caption: is a conversation on so I'm a 15 year
Caption: old son my absolute secret weapon in
Caption: life continually comes down from as
Caption: bedroom upstairs and kinds of for
Caption: most-hated words in the English language
Caption: not are we being it used to do that we
Caption: debate but have you heard about
Caption: I mean God on a charge on the resilience
Caption: of our old motivation to technological
Caption: change as fifteen-year-old gives me
Caption: every three two argument about this
Caption: pinterest just book Instapaper
Caption: and I'm learning to deal with that but
Caption: across this lifestyle you know you give
Caption: this up and what the hell
Caption: Facebook bought oculus what's their
Caption: agenda then I read ready player one and
Caption: I figured out their agenda completely
Caption: and some are on this time I'll tell you
Caption: a conversation have to guess where it is
Caption: along this line here so percent in your
Caption: old Boyd and is dead and his dad's
Caption: hanging up but he'll give me one of
Caption: those you don't need one of those we've
Caption: already got something perfectly good in
Caption: the house you get a headache from it
Caption: there's nothing on it anyway there's no
Caption: content conscious expensive and just
Caption: another gadget you don't talk your
Caption: brother than Apple wedding and I'll
Caption: never get you outside now that is that
Caption: someone talking to their seven-year-old
Caption: about freaking hololens or Samsung gear
Caption: cuz nothing on it'll give you a headache
Caption: you want to go outside won't talk to
Caption: your friends it's my dad talking to me
Caption: on the phone that we did not need a
Caption: television Nigel in 1970 and it's true
Caption: you see the television didn't start for
Caption: lunchtime going to finished at nine
Caption: o'clock one channel black-and-white game
Caption: you're in it is a revolution associate
Caption: and we've right here that word now all
Caption: those words I got a hot pepper thing so
Caption: that's the thing give the Rs
Caption: but there's no rulebook about this I
Caption: didn't think mobile web was a fair part
Caption: of the team that completed bankrupted
Caption: Lonely Planet on that basis basically
Caption: take this out of your pocket than an
Caption: iPhone 3G who didn't have rubbish they
Caption: work terrible screen batteries on my
Caption: lunchtime the phone isn't work anyway
Caption: and it only worked on Wi-Fi to actually
Caption: browse the web on the terrible life to
Caption: that pocket with there is no chance in
Caption: the world ever that anybody is going to
Caption: take a $1,500 computer out of their
Caption: pocket and walk down a street and perd
Caption: looking for a place to find a coffee now
Caption: we lived in an instant
Caption: walking down pastry this morning trying
Caption: to find a coffee which incidentally and
Caption: to us by the way thank God for the
Caption: enhancer and those that same two roses I
Caption: don't think I fool anyone not having a
Caption: $1,500 computer out of their pocket
Caption: looking for a place to park on there may
Caption: have been hunting Pokemon I'm pretty
Caption: sure they were looking for a place or
Caption: coffee just by me
Caption: so do you need to make those in safe you
Caption: know in this world those and things just
Caption: keep moving on faster faster this is TV
Caption: as we know it today
Caption: I'm guessing not to even watch the damn
Caption: thing anymore that TVs my 15 year old
Caption: know that he watches on that what
Caption: is going on the screen over here is but
Caption: a finite oven tasting is nice and all
Caption: those garlic
Caption: so that's television as we know it now
Caption: for this not television evolution I work
Caption: at a media Tommy where 6110 owned by
Caption: News Corp it handles and cool people at
Caption: their television coming in there it is
Caption: incredible and working on training and
Caption: they are are really important to me as a
Caption: partnership
Caption: koala news book of NOAA incredible
Caption: because the future is about those medias
Caption: I've got a big family to draw props that
Caption: is not TV at all that's TV now who knew
Caption: that would happen and you're the first
Caption: adopters of the fewer launch which
Caption: watching videos of England playing games
Caption: two weeks ago thinking that's called
Caption: courtly is cool and how you learn and
Caption: that's waiting people who are generally
Caption: 52 years old the television now runs on
Caption: this device and there's an interactive
Caption: chat component to it in a bit of a
Caption: mission
Caption: it'll happen though so become expert in
Caption: that people watch twitch and play games
Caption: the other thing I find interesting is
Caption: our ability to cope with exponential
Caption: change in technology I had to read three
Caption: times the article my team gives me about
Caption: because the hardware of this was
Caption: revealed this week at a conference there
Caption: is a CPU in there that is the size of
Caption: your finger now that manages one
Caption: trillion instructions per second god I
Caption: don't
Caption: my captain I don't even have any zeros
Caption: on us and surviving the city of this
Caption: thing that it's almost entirely a
Caption: hardware device so we're story is
Caption: something people log into they're coming
Caption: oh yeah that was the first time there
Caption: was a cool animation I almost shading
Caption: and all the stuff so this is the end of
Caption: our more Toy Story of 1995 it is an
Caption: astonishing stack of computer than god
Caption: help the poor take you had to pinch the
Caption: heart translation of that same power in
Caption: 1/2 of the CPU power of my iPhone 6 in
Caption: that time in than 20 years and a man
Caption: that is replaced by that it's remarkable
Caption: there must have been a patient I take
Caption: people indoors or greater in a bill that
Caption: size on that bar I've just been at
Caption: Singapore which is one of the wonderful
Caption: part so much on this there's a lot
Caption: Singapore look I think put things
Caption: together that we all need to put
Caption: together right so in our in Cisco the
Caption: arts kids with that life and the science
Caption: kids in that way and I'm going to use
Caption: dilemmas I'm going to like both but
Caption: there's not many people why both so go
Caption: to Singapore and write a hundred they
Caption: have an art science museum one would Ark
Caption: science and the most remarkable way got
Caption: the incredibly divisionism to
Caption: instructing life 2011 an artist printed
Caption: out every photo that would have uploaded
Caption: this live here in 24 hours since I met
Caption: it is a million photos and they're
Caption: sneaking up on as plug in a bit
Caption: more chicken wire under there so I'd
Caption: argue you're allowed to there's a
Caption: million photos printed over sponsored by
Caption: Conan
Caption: album now on instagrams that take a
Caption: million photos to be uploaded we reckon
Caption: an hour about 15 minutes 15 minutes
Caption: remaining five we didn't visit that was
Caption: going to happen I thought it was cool to
Caption: me like that I'm by eye and what I need
Caption: to pee really think that's cool but it
Caption: is kind of cool because they're doing a
Caption: million dollars a month in America and
Caption: Google design comes with what a good one
Caption: cause it's a question I get make your
Caption: living I don't you get thought through
Caption: the answer on what it is relatively
Caption: simple he's got a thing like a Boston
Caption: 5.7 billion out of the year it's been
Caption: driving cars in America if you were
Caption: driving cars one of those Americans
Caption: going to do I get this to bite down get
Caption: on YouTube revenue when you're going to
Caption: get on social media and watch TV in a
Caption: chat you do all the things that generate
Caption: media revenue that's probably the
Caption: greatest release of media time in the
Caption: last 20 years
Caption: brilliant idea no wonder they're putting
Caption: so much effort into it because I think I
Caption: love this I said one things I love to
Caption: love tonight
Caption: you know we first had Google Camaro was
Caption: really bloody obvious when something
Caption: with an ad we're down the right-hand
Caption: side in your Gmail or in the top of the
Caption: thing it look like a really crap link
Caption: compared to the cool links below I look
Caption: at the evolution of links design through
Caption: to the current day or how is it it's
Caption: more garden back to the both Facebook
Caption: and Google roster that is exactly the
Caption: same UX and UI and an ordinary piece of
Caption: content on Google so didn't take long I
Caption: can tell exactly where they garden from
Caption: it
Caption: she's a little bit nerve-racking for me
Caption: because I you know in terms of
Caption: competitors in the real estate market
Caption: nice to think except we conspired the
Caption: night of it that's cool bigger than ever
Caption: to the right you know she actually make
Caption: all that power
Caption: any dooms my competitor what did they
Caption: build alpha gotta look at if it goes on
Caption: you all want any other Christmas
Caption: stocking this year a device about this
Caption: thing that can play go I would
Caption: expect our to be in a go clothes and
Caption: goes later than the rest I can tell you
Caption: that IQ applies to human beings is not
Caption: actually normal
Caption: because it's a really complicated day my
Caption: struggling later be to death what they
Caption: do now all the guys have all the brain
Caption: power that it took to meet Lisa doll for
Caption: one in that tournament and this is a lot
Caption: mocking them as we did it wind it big
Caption: blue big Castro during those nine foot
Caption: awards on a bit but like nineties will
Caption: say and that's on the yield times
Caption: poverty headline saying okay well these
Caption: computers have done they've been the guy
Caption: chest but it's not that complicated
Caption: it will take a century so that anyone to
Caption: build a computer that can be a human
Caption: being at the games go good luck
Caption: let's provide that Nevada what a century
Caption: at all less than twenty years I love
Caption: about that because all that technology
Caption: going one place is not telling you to go
Caption: console for the two hours two hundred
Caption: human beings you can actually play the
Caption: games in this room things you may want
Caption: fine thank you mobile phones going to
Caption: you self-driving cars and you're going
Caption: to talk to it and it's all going to
Caption: happen together in this kind of mad
Caption: cloud of scary because all these
Caption: data spy and all over the place but a
Caption: very very clever doing and everything
Caption: like that it's in the world hope you've
Caption: all seen this video there's kind of
Caption: thing of what the world is like and it
Caption: means in reality then we like pinch of
Caption: that in this kind of thing you know if
Caption: you silent it pops up with the clap that
Caption: you need to upgrade with those teeny
Caption: message and when you're not driving your
Caption: time your windows are all been to the
Caption: reality streams you'll get the same
Caption: message for system updates required but
Caption: it really does enrich the world people
Caption: want easy to hit pokemon when you car
Caption: driving every time that so this is what
Caption: we believe it is how we talk we go back
Caption: that's not the guy I made the coffee for
Caption: this morning that I wrote a group of
Caption: your beam under for looks a bit like and
Caption: actually at the hundred
Caption: years ago does Charles Darwin wrote a
Caption: book called on the origin of speaking it
Caption: is the most agile book if it wasn't this
Caption: guy he was a great businessman run
Caption: there's a brand new field he rewrote the
Caption: book five times five editions every time
Caption: taking any more compensation hadn't
Caption: heard in what was social media of the
Caption: day which were town hall meetings and
Caption: various other things and rewrote it that
Caption: one page another journalist faulted
Caption: expensive review is brought in
Caption: suggesting to read this one it's just
Caption: survival of the fittest so he didn't
Caption: actually invent that phrase even has
Caption: widely associated with Talon Talon like
Caption: that what else deserve it operas
Caption: whatever there's been some is a paper
Caption: clip so well Microsoft
Caption: Clippy it would censorship join those
Caption: dots anyway the problem with survival of
Caption: the fittest is it sounds like you see
Caption: how I translated that for you
Caption: not survival toast it is the levity that
Caption: former that is it things like ask the
Caption: biggest the strongest the fastest the
Caption: biggest taste the most resources the
Caption: hive market cap on the Australian Stock
Caption: Exchange
Caption: we woke up about three years ago going
Caption:  a little about without being number
Caption: one and the biggest and the fastest and
Caption: the richest in the stronger hold it
Caption: scientifically the least likely to
Caption: survive the things that survive and have
Caption: resilience between all what a prayer
Caption: organizations in particular we want job
Caption: continues time it to be responsive to
Caption: challenge a being responsive to change
Caption: the quite whole new mindset of title
Caption: this is what happens when you're not
Caption: I don't many of you been to San
Caption: Francisco in recent times I have to show
Caption: this slider in town and December last
Caption: year basically on a third side of evil
Caption: look go there right in the yellow cab
Caption: because you tell me grandchildren about
Caption: us what if I think I'm going to believe
Caption: you you get all the yellow cavities and
Caption: shitty old copies to drive down the
Caption: street like this and a slow down when
Caption: this in you which I'll catch you in the
Caption: eye
Caption: and get experience that you know you're
Caption: going to do is that oh you mean like
Caption: smoking what that to point out on
Caption: whatever it is in 2035 which is
Caption: Magnusson one crazy business model now
Caption: they used to be 1400 trips a month and
Caption: now is 400 and in January they chose the
Caption: chapter 11 bankruptcy you can get new
Caption: grander lift for those on their board in
Caption: San Francisco and you you're not they're
Caption: going to informative wait for a new
Caption: bottom from San Francisco so it's
Caption: gone we thought it was there forever but
Caption: it's gone the unintended consequences
Caption: are things I'm always interested in it's
Caption: where the social scientist and he comes
Caption: out so I always ask who the tribe is how
Caption: they got to be a little drier so factor
Caption: in question these are the people at the
Caption: leading edge of change in our economy
Caption: because they are willing to be criminals
Caption: to try something different that we just
Caption: legalized uber and Victoria somehow
Caption: ended up I mean $2.00 tax for every trip
Caption: to the dinosaur industry but that's ok I
Caption: asked this bloke one date and it took me
Caption: a bit particularly nice car she said
Caption: well how do you become an image I'm not
Caption: really an engine driver I'm actually a
Caption: new that teacher I started a school in
Caption: what I think that a driver like come on
Caption: you can oh no 5000 uber drivers and
Caption: hours every week 200 drop out because if
Caption: their score that you bright at them on
Caption: goes below that 4.6 the end at goes
Caption: blank
Caption: as reported many quarters in come on two
Caption: weeks to get enrolled in the school
Caption: include your act pass the exam and he
Caption: gets 30 drives to ensure you're above
Caption: four point five nine stars out of five
Caption: okay holy that's a level of
Caption: transparency we're not really used to
Caption: out here in the real world what we've
Caption: ended up in useful is if 75% of people
Caption: in my school used to have one job what
Caption: was it
Caption: taxi driver and this is one of the
Caption: problem that the inertia caused by kind
Caption: of learned incapacity
Caption: taxi drivers have never
Caption: that you have to talk to the passenger
Caption: will keep your car 20 because the 50
Caption: years they hadn't bought it but when he
Caption: is that not reflects the
Caption: suspension of their car which makes me
Caption: ill and every taxi I get into even he
Caption: feels agree you business had an
Caption: opportunity that didn't even exist two
Caption: years ago that's what I wanted that to
Caption: reality and invention along the way
Caption: creates new opportunities so we
Caption: shouldn't feed it too much of us change
Caption: that like making good money from that
Caption: it's going to go there in a subside to
Caption: it though because you've got a rating as
Caption: well who knows the over arrow numerating
Caption: you're in right here what's your score
Caption: out of five stars
Caption: cool what did you do wrong I bought one
Caption: hang on I have the natural human
Caption: reaction
Caption: who's the air hub around me down I'm a
Caption: nice quiet you what you're doing as you
Caption: know it's called me avoid but that's why
Caption: I'm cool with that
Caption: now there's more tolerance for
Caption: misbehavior from consumers and there is
Caption: from drivers the store which urban start
Caption: disappearing off your screen and nobody
Caption: picked you up its forward to so watch
Caption: yourself and he saw a cab or racially
Caption: abused a driver need you that a tactical
Caption: towing that because they're relation
Caption: you're using your back said do that in
Caption: the mood but you've done what's going to
Caption: happen and if I you know get picked up
Caption: so that bought a hotel in an American
Caption: woman outside they don't tell each other
Caption: in this Congress it's a terrible there's
Caption: always some zest reduction she's right
Caption: that's like and now one within ten
Caption: minutes
Caption: so what else I need to get home as well
Caption: six cars within soon that Oh what have
Caption: you coded that probably I'm just on some
Caption: time no no you might lose I'll just go
Caption: over here
Caption: and what happens in that world where you
Caption: no longer unite you no longer and all
Caption: the other cars are gone
Caption: it also bankrupt another got public
Caption: transport at least in Melbourne was
Caption: going to be a lot of walking goes on or
Caption: secret opportunity as an unintended
Caption: consequence the yellow cab of shame you
Caption: know what we solve those basic problems
Caption: of racial abuse and soiling cab because
Caption: then dumbass white car then Google Wave
Caption: something like a bucket upside down
Caption: landing on the inside you just hose the
Caption: vomit out goes out to the fleet recycle
Caption: that thing in five minutes and there's
Caption: no driver to amuse so unintended
Caption: consequences always think the true pink
Caption: Christ nobody remover is interested in
Caption: real estate two weeks ago up to
Caption: tower Monday one of the founders of over
Caption: the solid real estate was next push the
Caption: company called house numbers I think
Caption: he's got it wrong it made a classic
Caption: error of business people I'm not
Caption: understanding the difference between a
Caption: complex problem domain and an obvious
Caption: simple problem to maximum you may know
Caption: the commitment framework you know simple
Caption: problems you just buy the software or do
Caption: what you did last time
Caption: complex problems it's an ecosystem
Caption: problem everything's connected to
Caption: everything and woe betide you if you try
Caption: to set aside by buying s AP because you
Caption: just find to create that that's like an
Caption: obstacles in a string open day and real
Caption: estate in one of those problems which
Caption: what clearly attracts me to a lot of a
Caption: lot of hypnotism so I think you messed
Caption: it up and exactly the same system
Caption: complete transparency of the transaction
Caption: of the people doing it now if it means
Caption: interest accounting for these because
Caption: it's a deity of these run and a
Caption: brilliant story that up first of all God
Caption: and founded light as long as this side
Caption: looks brilliant you know the user
Caption: interface is astonishing and I wish
Caption: might a little bit like that looks
Caption: really well now the tricky everyone
Caption: things did it here over the month of
Caption: that in America a lot it four and a half
Caption: years before you freak out about medical
Caption: costs and tuition costs the kids and
Caption: what do I have taken all that you five
Caption: days vacation each year you worry about
Caption: that stuff so haven't your front ribs or
Caption: me it would be great all you can look at
Caption: extra cash too
Caption: things that cover your insurance costs
Caption: the chocolate that's not we the truth
Caption: about Airbnb and you look at airbnb.com
Caption: today is full of slash sublets SUV LMT
Caption: they've launched a property management
Caption: server so it in longer leases six and
Caption: twelve months
Caption: this one looks like in the area are
Caption: either them plenty of properties four
Caption: legs and this is happening big time that
Caption: you know that Australia has the highest
Caption: penetration in a single suburb of Indian
Caption: Venus their properties its Channel Rama
Caption: that's taken me a month or them to say
Caption: that where father as on Tama Rama
Caption: jamorama 20% of the entire how things
Caption: talking that some of it listed on Airbnb
Caption: and here's the myth-busting right
Caption: if not mums and dads leasing out that
Caption: front room it's people leasing a whole
Caption: house out on the longer-term basis as
Caption: well so it changed the story of the
Caption: changes not obvious difference I
Caption: encourage you're always we're going to
Caption: mix the problem and then you can
Caption: download this app if you want to and
Caption: become an Airbnb property manager now
Caption: you can manage a dozen properties using
Caption: this test you're pretty brilliant
Caption: platform woken me up to go while
Caption: I'm playing with hollow lenses I need to
Caption: build an app real quick for property
Caption: managers is that angry people in
Caption: Australia because of the lack of
Caption: transparency of the people who have to
Caption: deal with continuously checking
Caption: references extracts they're they're
Caption: worried and then we're going to tell
Caption: them to heart the properties of things
Caption: we've released an arbitrage to their
Caption: being better get even more stress where
Caption: they can walk away from their business
Caption: and what they got is happen to start
Caption: their own property management business
Caption: which would be cool example one an
Caption: economic factor about the property will
Caption: you probably didn't know if I'm 65 years
Caption: old and I'm thinking about retiring to
Caption: Paul it C or Fremantle
Caption: selling my real estate agency have your
Caption: even the price of my real estate agency
Caption: is established and the same way you'll
Caption: start up your companies whatever you've
Caption: got is future revenue multiple of all
Caption: those kind of things which component of
Caption: real estate revenue is the future value
Caption: of your agency value dot and this is how
Caption: many hotshots album you have selling
Caption: houses that options or selling houses of
Caption: the weekend
Caption: it's how big is your political mentor
Caption: role a much money to get from managing
Caption: rental products because it's repeatable
Caption: stable
Caption: and those people don't leave and go to
Caption: the next agency every you know maybe
Caption: three years or so so you have a medium
Caption: now eating away at the rental income of
Caption: these agencies so 65 years old watching
Caption: the value of my business get eaten by an
Caption: American company people borrow money
Caption: against the multiple of their involves
Caption: evaluation of their business highly in
Caption: decibel dispensers because if ambitious
Caption: and boiling up other agencies so this is
Caption: actually one of those bizarre qualities
Caption: that come to an industry you've got to
Caption: keep your eyes open for the don't worry
Caption: about them what did William Lillian do
Caption: since my sign is quite to write I think
Caption: the future is already here it's just
Caption: really unevenly distributed great quite
Caption: hot use at the moment really unevenly
Caption: distributed in real estate means
Caption: Kalgoorlie I mean the people in this
Caption: room don't even know if I can cowboy
Caption: here I'm finding on that you know what's
Caption: going on there is because the teacher is
Caption: already here and the futures facebook is
Caption: my competitor and I got 15 down hotshot
Caption: engineers right property is now being
Caption: sold at least in a thing called buy sell
Caption: swap pros an excellent example one of
Caption: the key factors of the real estate
Caption: industry that it all works enabled it's
Caption: human beings belong to try to enable
Caption: that's not often move much beyond their
Caption: neighborhoods and here it is for all
Caption: your real estate needs the Kalgoorlie
Caption: Boulder real estate by itself rip to it
Caption: then you live with a marketing help on
Caption: the title because many mental properties
Caption: is respect at home today you know I've
Caption: just deployed a person an Account
Caption: Manager out there because this is the
Caption: front line of the war between Australian
Caption: companies and American companies
Caption: Kalgoorlie
Caption: figures to us so that's a fantastic
Caption: thing as a global player managing to
Caption: play logical in we need to think locally
Caption: it start you know which is kind of how
Caption: we started with a slight Australia but
Caption: the government America Little Italy well
Caption: then lots of it the worse places we need
Caption: to think the opposite way
Caption: I think you can start mobile you can
Caption: well sort this on myself Lapras
Caption: this is the chance to the 150 thousand
Caption: dollar home coming off the famine hole
Caption: determine if ifelse walkers are just the
Caption: baby clothes feed bucks through the door
Caption: you know and on pay is slamming and
Caption: playing them on Facebook what's the
Caption: worst that could happen
Caption: the only other business model in the
Caption: world with the good stain on the front
Caption: Stephanie 14 buck sure there's always
Caption: what drug dealing retribution would you
Caption: often see a misleading everyone $50,000
Caption: couple on the side they used to tell ten
Caption: god Oxana baby clothes
Caption: we just recently invested in business
Caption: with News Corp of Husqvarna we just kind
Caption: of linked within our family around
Caption: hundred heads and what everybody's got a
Caption: network of plumbers you know a lot of
Caption: people moved to Melbourne like me I
Caption: don't have my plumber training network
Caption: at my fingertips so high pages is a
Caption: great service for sorting at our
Caption: transparency ratings trustworthiness all
Caption: those things several million problems
Caption: for this is my friends at musical and
Caption: here's the competition
Caption: it's a buy-sell slaughter dead I need a
Caption: handyman to realign a lock on the door
Caption: I've got some bottles of wine seasonings
Caption: of carrots spinach and lettuce there
Caption: help you down with so I can tell you
Caption: something to this my pension doesn't go
Caption: far enough to come up with $100 call out
Caption: the hot water
Caption: what's hi page is basic business model
Caption: you've probably got the same this is all
Caption: several companies in here as we take 20
Caption: bucks 700 bucks for making the link in
Caption: the ecosystem let's see what happens
Caption: next
Caption: Rob says I'm working in Newport today if
Caption: you're close I'll drop in I called out
Caption: these we're old school well you
Caption: right that's my business model Assyria
Caption: and it's my different ecosystem Roxanne
Caption: trouble comes Matt wary where I get it
Caption: I'll pop in and fix it for free the
Caption: devil's own idea a neighbor and that's
Caption: what you do than you we
Caption: so now neighborhoods neighbors I kind of
Caption: love it I hate it as I think Dave comes
Caption: in says I'm also willing to help out the
Caption: free and DD with the pensioner who I do
Caption: have 74 so the trade on a neighborhood
Caption: basis like she worked on a hundred years
Caption: ago you buy ads on Facebook there's a
Caption: mobile section called property within
Caption: local market that's fantastic medicine
Caption: you want you probably wrote the pot that
Caption: presents that this looks just like a
Caption: property portal there I was I just
Caption: predict you know just goes through your
Caption: eat with your friends our friends in
Caption: your geography and find a whole bunch of
Caption: things that look like property with a
Caption: price on it
Caption: whether it's rent house share or sale
Caption: pops it into that click on that even the
Caption: detail click on that you can look at the
Caption: agency its Jose from very boss real
Caption: estate so I can check customer online
Caption: not a customer at all just a boy I mean
Caption: California has against a bit of trouble
Caption: they're not paying taxes right that is a
Caption: bit of a problem our deliverer was
Caption: fighting startups is that they are ideas
Caption: searching for a business model and I
Caption: have a gigantic amount of cash and with
Caption: which to find efforts as well how much
Caption: mine you can over mate I as I've 570
Caption: billion in the third half million in the
Caption: first apnea probably could be looking
Caption: about Nivea and I got that's very
Caption: billion in cash just simply having
Caption: burned getting through the legal
Caption: dilemmas of being a criminal
Caption: organization building a mark and
Caption: acquiring drivers and figuring out the
Caption: business models until they crush the
Caption: taxi industry what are they doing in
Caption: food moving delivery action saying
Caption: anyway he's the faith in the future in
Caption: Los Angeles the government arts and very
Caption: specifically what proportion of your
Caption: income comes from mums and dads with the
Caption: front room two men so you kids can go to
Caption: college and what proportion of your
Caption: income comes from professional property
Caption: managers using your website and they
Caption: platform or not work to get a real
Caption: estate agency
Caption: well you reckon slippers because
Caption: two-thirds another thing with a B&B a
Caption: month of that remember my quote the
Caption: future is already here it's just really
Caption: unevenly distributed
Caption: in San Francisco the ratio is 25% of
Caption: their in
Caption: comes from professional property
Caption: managers they know not to shift in their
Caption: own back to your HUD because the
Caption: authorities there are angry about hotel
Caption: tax and various other things
Caption: Los Angeles is miles away 89 percent of
Caption: their income comes from property
Caption: managers managing multiple properties
Caption: one nice thing
Caption: get your eyes open it's already gone
Caption: somebody already juice Martian thinking
Caption: to go up the rules not what would you do
Caption: that's what you do we have to think the
Caption: same way you know in a world where this
Caption: like mm even put a hint it on and watch
Caption: him come into a stadium to talk to the
Caption: activity and fantastic smiles over a
Caption: remote control money public you can take
Caption: nine and there we go
Caption: that's way cooler to do this is a habit
Caption: you know people get kind of pull off and
Caption: a bit yuck without the whole VR thing
Caption: because they think that's going to
Caption: happen anyway that'll happens at this
Caption: I'm going to find had on the front only
Caption: gets punched between the eyes was harder
Caption: it doesn't hurt too much but this has
Caption: happened so that's Facebook that's all
Caption: the others this is that this is Google
Caption: so except by thousands of all places to
Caption: go discovering in competition two of us
Caption: went to South by Southwest only went
Caption: because I'm you they're going to have
Caption: some cool be hasta and this company
Caption: called 10x with the head of the show
Caption: they launched holographic real estate
Caption: agents and they just use the old
Caption: cheating fills it dr. Dre or James II or
Caption: who is a dead rapper that appear on the
Caption: glass shield and that's kind of cool
Caption: I'll tell you what nothing drives real
Caption: estate agents and being replaced by a
Caption: robot a digital robot even scarier right
Caption: so this is Google
Caption: 10x they call the great branch local
Caption: brands are selling real estate books
Caption: rights and I've got Kalgoorlie Facebook
Caption: over these guys coming in under tending
Caption: so they built it on the base
Caption: on a ship box company hull option calm
Caption: it removes the agent wrong model and
Caption: that was pretty clever because they sold
Caption: 30 billion dollars of property like that
Caption: that's why we're in America because
Caption: there's more people besar than there are
Caption: in Australia - brilliant marks to be
Caption: part of but it is a complex domain so
Caption: you have to have that mindset of
Caption: understanding how to do that now they
Caption: are already taking pictures of all my
Caption: deadly business and now whether it's
Caption: called business view that's inside of a
Caption: restaurant these blokes I don't worry
Caption: about countries catch up to guys and the
Caption: Flinders Ranges or the kangaroo and a
Caption: floppy hat and called spalling - a for
Caption: exploit and print on the side of the
Caption: world is it actually cut and paste
Caption: components our gum tree to make it look
Caption: like a web site the nuances that
Caption: like what's the donor country everything
Caption: country the soul even the houses so we
Caption: all ignore and laugh and get in our
Caption: youth while country so last
Caption: Thursday the chick is the 67,000
Caption: property listings on gumtree and who
Caption: actually owns it the zoom rice with the
Caption: floppy hat in the kangaroo
Caption: eBay are this the deliberate strategy of
Caption: different strategies may high entry to
Caption: this country make a bit of money along
Caption: the way and it's trying to actually
Caption: illegal for me to collaborate too
Caption: closely with karo and seek because they
Caption: don't want their monopoly position
Caption: emerging again that the media had in the
Caption: nineties have a look at their agenda
Caption: cars and vehicles jobs and realisation
Caption: interesting how much tax do they pay
Caption: Australia last year a lot you will you
Caption: would have all done it we've got
Caption: geofilters on snapchat building
Caption: invisible lines around open for
Caption: inspection so they don't over there is
Caption: non-existent and they probably have no
Caption: right to sell kids step over the line
Caption: then take a photo to go snapchat frame
Caption: advertising the real estate agent
Caption: again it's a bit of an idea of the
Caption: product idea looking for a business
Caption: model they will do anything painting
Caption: whatever it takes
Caption: snapchat will reappear mm anyone
Caption: be thinking is this terrific season shot
Caption: of your eyes you'd be sending a 50 lakhs
Caption: why not peer-to-peer platform and
Caption: blocking to the interesting converts and
Caption: processing album coming women and
Caption: business we reckon a little lucky with
Caption: an excuse for the older demographics has
Caption: maybe eight ten percent of our users
Caption: have an ad blocker so design an ad
Caption: blocker works as an app on your phone
Caption: and walks ads and every single other
Caption: apps which one included Isis right back
Caption: so they're they're pretty cool breeze to
Caption: go it I tell you now I go to a different
Caption: population line line 300 engineers like
Caption: 70% of them have an ad blocker on they
Caption: just think that's normal
Caption: they get confused with some of these
Caption: slacks oh my god have you seen the ad on
Caption: the homepage they go
Caption: me and heads on it's like that's a
Caption: freakish cut through statistical
Caption: deviation away from the real world but
Caption: this is going to be a big forum but then
Caption: actually it's about what you do needs
Caption: that's clever is about learning that
Caption: relationship with that gets you
Caption: Commission based marketing all those
Caption: kind of things so take that as a
Caption: challenge it's not a threat picture I'll
Caption: jump over but everyone now is what a
Caption: mobile app with the value of every
Caption: property in Australia and run so is it
Caption: an interesting book we're a pretty
Caption: successful large company that the
Caption: technology live competition is an
Caption: unprecedented rate what are we done we
Caption: got involved it's really tools that was
Caption: cool they were doing technology with a
Caption: company called menopause just a
Caption: hypothesis it's December the crackling
Caption: on the site hacked it in holy the
Caption: engagement factor from people seeing
Caption: self-powered and a walk through a house
Caption: off the planet we start tapping into the
Caption: psychology of consumers which is an
Caption: incredibly important thing to do so we
Caption: bought the company so we didn't listen
Caption: to joy being part of the musical group
Caption: they wrote the check and have no part of
Caption: the matter what company was just
Caption: fantastic because their pipeline to me
Caption: of their beta software is going to give
Caption: me an incredible advantage you get a
Caption: matter I brought what we've done with
Caption: their leader software and turning 3d
Caption: tools into actual serious double
Caption: walkthroughs
Caption: this is our very first causal around
Caption: making it whatever will look like this
Caption: is the one that made the ladies sick
Caption: well then she hasn't stunned us a little
Caption: bit we were stone-cold dead she said I
Caption: think it's odd that the couch doesn't
Caption: work like that
Caption: so again really interesting engineering
Caption: challenge and all credits my crew that
Caption: are really inventive minds have domed
Caption: our cabinet to constrain what should we
Caption: do because no means house number sort of
Caption: account of the properties at home on the
Caption: couch while you're watching The Biggest
Caption: Loser Hey because a new clue the smell
Caption: on the visible you put it on and be you
Caption: have something swivel like and super
Caption: tempting look at the airport aging the
Caption: people working on my VR and AR it's a
Caption: lot younger I can tell you that they
Caption: love getting out there and talking to
Caption: people and figure out how it works and
Caption: in something to do that and this is what
Caption: they came up with this was the first
Caption: design oh my god you've got like a
Caption: robotic laser beam to figure out how to
Caption: kind of help sleep and you put a little
Caption: what's one bedroom it's read of exact
Caption: exact and so you do have a tap
Caption: on here and then that's what they
Caption: invented sleeping that's a bit fun going
Caption: to come over to the left like that
Caption: that's what I came up was carrying a
Caption: little bit like that and I've got a
Caption: version they had said to brag about this
Caption: is our augmented reality adventure
Caption: beginning I'm jerky we came in with
Caption: their idea that bill proteins accompany
Caption: in museums you see Luke my check
Caption: engineer around the inventions oh this
Caption: is
Caption: they are come on that never take off so
Caption: you can imagine how I paid off on Luke
Caption: chadwick over Pokemon guy
Caption: they are mainstream now people expect it
Caption: on their phone they know looks and
Caption: stuffs so fantastic it's a company
Caption: called platter and again wonderful thing
Caption: of being part of of Examiners big
Caption: checkbook use court bought into them
Caption: they made this thing with us which was
Caption: about hate going on I believe it's over
Caption: anymore Nagy it's a trouble hang out at
Caption: three hundred engineers and none of them
Caption: do read the paper anymore but a lot of
Caption: consumers do and he wants to tell you
Caption: I'll kid go tap-tap-tap trying to make
Caption: the picture bigger
Caption: altogether what you could do that by
Caption: getting your own and holding it over us
Caption: that'd be cool and then they can hang in
Caption: the air make it magic not just pop to
Caption: your website make it magic and that's
Caption: what we did turn that into whole
Caption: neighborhoods with in gotta measure them
Caption: I've only explained in this code so it's
Caption: more rings right try to put the ring on
Caption: this is wispy white weird layer of you
Caption: noticing the data in our world you can
Caption: hear conversations mall all the way and
Caption: you understand what the spiders say
Caption: sometimes would have been there bit like
Caption: will mention reality neighborhoods have
Caption: data flowing all through them and if I
Caption: think would have phone up and tap that I
Caption: can find a value of that house I can see
Caption: the video of this one I can see what
Caption: their plans are and that's what we
Caption: tapped into with an idea mentorship
Caption: that's actually something pretty
Caption: interesting that's where the hylians
Caption: came in and then you can I do to our
Caption: place we have a very multidisciplinary
Caption: approach stuff diver there's these key
Caption: diversity profession of gender everyone
Caption: so that's my finance manager trying to
Caption: book one of the first thing we probably
Caption: because she read the check but getting
Caption: to try out the Highlands and then this
Caption: thing's coming there daydream the
Caption: daydream is Google thinkable launch
Caption: people Christmas brilliant in 50 bucks
Caption: widget controller none of the stupid
Caption: stuff so the leap frogging of this
Caption: technology is incredible and it kind of
Caption: sat back and waited for HTC to figure
Caption: that out
Caption: this is how my books looks through the
Caption: eyes of a fifteen-year-old he doesn't
Caption: care what he wanted even know the name
Caption: of my some of his middle part prime what
Caption: he knows we live in so this is a map of
Caption: Sydney the red zones hi Indian bandwidth
Caption: yellow zones are not
Caption: a good one time how to be suitable for
Caption: grandparents well hi problem I live in a
Caption: two million dollar house and a
Caption: grandparent zone
Caption: he used the whole little display didn't
Caption: get a about valuations and low
Caption: communities I check a lot like five
Caption: hundred gigs a month on scene if I left
Caption: it on a hundred percent or all thirty
Caption: days I still could only download 250 and
Caption: robots that it's kind of a typical
Caption: beautiful robot to life I love riding my
Caption: customers I'm going to build robots that
Caption: sit inside about robots that we're
Caption: working on is if you make them friendly
Caption: and interactive and use that
Caption: intelligence they can become part of the
Caption: conversation and save time I have a
Caption: particular interest in this my mother
Caption: has dementia and I see the life she
Caption: lives and her dementia care going on
Caption: she really wouldn't matter if it
Caption: was a robot but it's friendly in the
Caption: size of the two of the robots are
Caption: interacting it's going to be great
Caption: because I get the same conversation
Caption: every time we go and see there's a robot
Caption: program or patient with the frightening
Caption: that providing this is this so quantum
Caption: computing got a quit that's frightening
Caption: that's writings 5g I don't any of you
Caption: understand the implications of an
Caption: Australian law ecology heaven that
Caption: should unleashes where the NBN hasn't
Caption: that's my diagram to explain how Bitcoin
Caption: works and distributed alleges which will
Caption: completely upset the property industry
Caption: and this is the lesson so we invented
Caption: this word inventor ship that is in fact
Caption: the spirit we have to do we have we have
Caption: separated inventions from innovation and
Caption: that's really important because you tell
Caption: people innovating again worried about
Caption: customers go into an event which is a
Caption: core talent of a country that came from
Caption: far around the world to Australia and
Caption: they'll out of wire and wood and
Caption: dirt we go to the data and this rooms
Caption: the inventors but absolutely encourage
Caption: you to engage that spirit in your
Caption: organization and I'm going to wind up in
Caption: businesses that are headquartered in
Caption: Silicon Valley thank you very much
Caption: you